hello everyone and welcome to another
really enjoyable game from round three
of the video grand prix 2022. now it's
averted versus do both uh and uh well
it's a it's a very well balanced game uh
until one player makes a slight
inaccuracy and the other one really
takes advantage of it nicely so let's
check it out and there will be a very
nice positive video moment so that it
with the white pieces opens with knight
to f3 he goes for that at the opening
and dubo goes for the symmetrical line
we have knight to f6 g3 g6 bishop to g2
and bishop to g7 we have d4 d5 and c4
and you can't keep the symmetry forever
because there's this thing in chess
called well check
so at some point the symmetry will break
so here uh we have c6 and now both
players castle so castles castles and
now queen to b3
uh nicely developing the queen uh
putting more pressure on the center also
the b7 pawn is attacked if the light
square bishop is developed and black
really wants to develop the light square
bishop so here a queen to b6 is what's
uh mostly played here just offering a
queen trait and then the game continues
however uh duboff plays a5 and it's more
of a
move that suits his style because you
can just play a4 at some point and try
and combine this with some other moves
so it's a uh it's um
more of a lovely game uh so here we have
c captures on d5 but the dubo does not
recapture he plays a4 and okay the queen
now has to move and best is to just
bring the queen back to the starting
square because if you play some like
queen to c2 then you can play bishop to
f5 attack the queen it's not not very
nice also the rook is probably coming to
see it at some point so the queen is
best just brought back to the starting
square we have c captures on d5 uh duval
reclaims the pawn and now knight the c3
continuing development and queen to a5
uh so the queen is now nicely developed
and you are already uh preparing some
tricks for example if white just plays
something like 95 it's a useful move you
want to play this at some point we can
play a3 and already the knight on c3 is
very weak so instead vidit plays bishop
to d2 now he's threatening some nasty
discoveries but for the moment you
really don't have a good one uh so dubo
just continues development knight to c6
we have e3 now and queen to a6
uh grabbing hold of this diagonal now
the the discoveries could become a
little bit scarier
and now there is a move where a game or
two where rook to e1 was played but the
vidiq plays the uh top move recommended
by the engine and that is b3 as uh it
would seem he came very well prepared so
it is now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game uh duba captures on
b3 we have queen capture sun b3 again
nicely developing the queen to b3 and
now dooba goes knight a5 attacks the
queen says all right where are you going
to put your queen duboff please uh sorry
versus plays queen before duval repeats
knight to c6 and now uh video doesn't go
queen back to b3 because this is only
move 15 and even though it's unlikely
that dooba would go for a repetition so
early on in the game you don't really
want to push it so here just the queen
back to b2 you have to fight for
advantage with white and now bishop to
f5 doom of continuous development we
have rook f2c1 as this is the only open
file on the board it's very natural to
place your rooks on the open file rook f
the c8 do both does the same and only
now knight to e5 and this is just a
beautiful square for the white knight um
you you don't really want to capture
this uh even
okay now you can't capture
because of tactics the d5 pawn will be
hanging but you pretty much never want
to capture this so here queen to a3
duboff offers a queen trade and now with
its trades we have queen captures rook
captures and again he weakens the d5
pawn by playing g4 so he wants to remove
one of the defenders and uh duo has to
decide whether to play something like
bishop to e6 but that's again going to
be met with the g5 and again we're going
to remove the defender of of the d5 pawn
so instead adobo just captures with
knight captures and g4 knight captures
bishop captures and now knight captures
on d5 so uh with it uh trader of his g
pawn uh for dubose a very strong d pawn
uh rook c to a8 putting pressure on the
a2 pawn and now knight to b4 or
defending the a2 pawn but also offering
a trade however if you go for this trade
then you will also be giving up the e7
pawn maybe for example captures captures
and captures and now we're going to
capture on e7 and now black has the b
pawn the the pass b pawn but vidid would
have the past the d pawn and the d-pawn
is uh a little bit stronger here for
example b5 we're gonna play bishop to c6
and now look at this uh with this bishop
here okay it's uh even uh it it even
comes to ceasing with tempo as the pawn
is attacked uh the problem is uh white's
bishops are controlling all of the
squares that the past pawn and needs to
cross in order to become a queen and
that's just unstoppable so it's very
easy to just push this pawn and the
black will have some issues doing the
same so instead after knight b4 we have
knights to a5 declining the trade now
rook a to b1 again there are some tricks
knights the b3 should win the game so
rook a to b1
and now bishop to f8 not only defending
our pawn here but we are preparing to
advance it and then we'll eliminate the
defender of the a2 pawn so here rook to
c7 again if your opponent allows it you
you have a the open file all for
yourself uh you want to play
put the rook on the seventh square
and now e6 is the move you have to play
here yeah and uh it definitely makes
sense but uh bishop to e6 is what do
both played he said all right my pawn is
defended let's just play bishop to e6
and pick up the a2 pawn it doesn't seem
like white can stop this really but
there is a move that really allows a
video to
take advantage of this inaccuracy
and i i could ask you to pause the video
here but uh it's too difficult to find
it so i'm going to show you a few moves
and then i'm going to ask you to pause
the video so here vidit plays d5 and
okay
the bishop has now been kicked away you
are no longer attacking the a2 pawn do
both plays bishop to g4 now that it
plays h3 he says all right you are
running out of squares duo says no
problem i have all the squares i need
bishop to f5 it even comes with tempo
i'm attacking your rook but now comes
the move that again you have to see and
that is e4 and well it's hard to believe
that this can even be played because now
uh not only is the bishop attacking h3
but since you've moved the pawn from the
third rank the rook is also attacking
the h3 pawn so there's really nothing
better we have to capture the pawn the
bishop captures on h3 is played and now
you will see the move uh that um uh
vidiq saw when he played that uh pawn
push uh
pawn to d5 and that is bishop to c1 so
you have to see all of this
in order to play that d5 move so now the
rook is attacked and all of these
squares are covered by white's pieces uh
the rook cannot keep defending the
bishop on h3 so here dupo has to give up
the exchange we have bishop captures an
a3 and okay bishop captures on e4
uh dubois has two extra pawns so that's
compensation in itself however
rook to e1 attacking the bishop and now
you have to play f5 here in order to
just try and survive as black however
duval plays bishop to f5 and now there
is only one winning move for dubo for
vidit but it's not easy to spot it so
feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only winning idea
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's night that's
not it it's night the c2 that's the good
stuff and this is the only move that
wins it's one of the weirder moves that
win the game we've seen in a while uh
but just uh uh well just to give an
example of why it's extremely strong if
you don't play this uh let's try to play
something else you want to bring the
king into the game once black plays e6
uh that's it you no longer have any
advantage because it doesn't matter what
you play for example captures captures
what do you play now let's say now you
try knight to c2 we're just going to
move the bishop bishop to g7 and black
has uh well
more than enough compensation however
after the move in the game knight to c2
now you have a problem now the e7 pawn
is hanging and if the e7 pawn falls then
you have a past the d-pawn and it's not
going to be easy to stop this and you
don't really have a good way of um
of stopping this if you play something
like e6 now we can just trade bishop
capture so rook captures and now well we
have all all sorts of moves
we can push d6 but even just a nice
knight to d4 uh is enough if he captures
on d5 we can play knight captures and
f5g captures and now well the two rooks
are just too strong black spawn
structure is completely messed up and
that's not um
not possible to defend
instead you could try rook to d8 you go
after the pawn makes sense but we can
play knight e3 that's why knight to c2
is also very strong now you can defend
your pawn and black's position is just
terrible let's say bishop to d3 we're
going to play something bishop to b for
now attacking the knight and once you
defend it we're going to play rook eat
the c1 and now uh with white having a
dark square bishop with the knight
having a very easy access to the king
side uh the bishop weirdly placed on f8
there's not much you can do here for
example h5 we're just gonna trade rooks
captures captures and now this is a
threat how do you stop this let's say
king d7 d6 is coming and now even after
e captures bishop to c3 check and now
look at this position uh king to g8 we
have to defend our bishop knight d5
coming to f6 this is a game over or even
e7 yeah and anything can just win here
so instead after knight to c2 dubose
says all right obviously i have to
capture the knight i can't give vidit a
move so bishop captures on c2 is played
rook captures in c2 and now comes knight
to c4 again if you try e6 now it's
simply not enough we're just going to
trade here or your king captures and
we're going to play rook to c7
and well
that's it
if you capture then we even grab the
seventh rank for ourselves and that's
that's game over so after rook captures
on c2 knight the c4 again offering some
traits uh but there is nothing better
rook capture so we have rook captures on
a3 and now even d6 if it shows that the
pawn no longer matters that the rooks
coming uh
into the game is is much too strong so
for example if captures just rook e8 if
king g7 rook c the c8 you don't even
have a square for the bishop so even
that's silly so after d6 we have e6 uh
stopping this but now creating a past
the d-pawn for for white so you can see
that video wanted to create a pass deep
on but then it wasn't even necessary but
just to keep the position alive dubo had
to allow the creation of the past pawn
so rook d1 now we have our rook behind
our past pawn that's uh well
rook captures on a2 was played d7 now
bishop to e7 there's no way to stop the
pawn you have to give up the bishop so
d8 queen captures captures with checking
the g8 now visit is just up a rook and a
few more moves were played rook to d7
going after the pawn here so rook a5 now
we're trying to defend the pawn with
rook to f5 but it doesn't matter rook f4
uh dubo defended we have rook captures
on f5e captures on f5 and now f4 or
pretty much any other move andy was in
this position
uh animal 43 that daniel dubo resigned
the game and a brilliant brilliant
victory for vidit here uh who who
spotted that uh
after dubose this uh after this move
uh was played uh that uh
he had this uh but it's such a long line
and you really had to figure out because
you can't just play d5 if if it doesn't
work it's going to be a liability so you
have to see all of that plus bishop to
c1 with an attack on the rook and that
the rook will not be able to defend the
bishop here so
really really crazy stuff uh so
really really awesome that vidiq saw all
of this and then he found the only
winning move knight to c2 that allows
him to create a pass pawn but not really
but then in the end uh it was inevitable
so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by vidit i would like
to thank meadow for breaking into the
room at the precise right moment triple
triangle daniel silverberg john black
and patrick mulcair for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
magnificent event
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day